good morning john so i've seen a bunch
of tweets for the last few days that
made me pretty angry which
you know makes it exactly like every
other few days in the last few years but
in this specific case it was tweets like
these the amazon rainforest is seeing a
record number of wildfires
large swaths of the amazon rainforest
are burning fires are raging
the amazon region is burning now mostly
this comes down to like a problem i have
with reality
which is that there's just too much of
it and thus it is very hard to be aware
of all of it
and so we end up with things that are
incomplete making their way into our
brain but if there's anything we should
be aware of
it's this because you know future of the
planet at stake and stuff like that
so why do i not like these tweets well
because here in america
uh where i live usually if there's a
wildfire it was an
accident and sometimes fires are okay
because fires are a normal part of
our ecosystems in america and sometimes
they were done on purpose by like
criminals who the government wants to
arrest and so when you read these
headlines as an american you think oh no
a fire happened i hope someone's trying
to put it out but in the amazon
fire is not a natural part of the
ecosystem and because of that
many trees in the rainforest can't
survive what we would in the u.s
consider a trivial burn
these fires are not natural they are
intentional this isn't
intentional like it's arson it's
intentional like this land is more
economically productive when we graze
cattle on it than when it's the
rainforest so the headline here
shouldn't be large swaths of the amazon
are burning it should be
large swaths of the amazon are being
burned now sometimes in the dry season
which we're in right now there are
natural wildfires in the amazon and in
fact
the number of natural wildfires appears
to be increasing
because here's a thing about the amazon
and other rainforests
with plenty of water and plenty of
sunlight the ecosystem is really good at
using
everything that comes its way that means
that most of the water that falls is
immediately released back into the
atmosphere by this tremendous amount of
vegetation
photosynthesis gets done when water
evaporates out of plants
a single tree can evaporate more than 50
000 gallons of water per year and once
that water's back in the atmosphere
it falls again rainforests don't just
thrive on rain
they make rain so when there's less
rainforest there's less rain
and more fires but that's not the real
reason there's so many more fires this
year it's not hotter than normal it's
not drier than normal the thing that
changed in brazil is who the president
did the moment he was elected
jair bolsonaro rolled back environmental
protections in brazil
earlier this month he fired the head of
brazil's national space and research
institute
after he defended data showing that
deforestation had grown 40
in the last year bolsonaro says that
figure is wrong and the deforestation is
down
that's a lie when asked why there are so
many fires this year bolsonaro said that
maybe environmental organizations are
setting them
to make him look bad that is also a lie
but this isn't just like pure
malice and like love of destruction
there's an ideology here there's the
economic part of it which is just that
there's a lot of value in the rainforest
and no one's making any money off of it
if it's just being rainforest and then
there's sort of an ideological thing of
like the civilizing interest of man we
must bring our superior way of life to
this
wild jungle racist manifest destiny kind
of stuff so to make the money you
encourage legal logging and farming you
reduce inspections reduce regulations
and you ignore
illegal land grabs where a forest is
slashed and
burned and then seeded with grass and
sold to ranchers
there's also another piece of the
ideology here that i think is really
interesting the reality is that most of
the good that the amazon
does is for everyone it produces
oxygen for everyone it traps co2 for
everyone
it preserves biodiversity for the whole
world
but brazil isn't getting paid for any of
that stuff
far-right perspectives ultra-nationalist
perspectives
don't really allow for stuff that helps
everyone
goes against this ideology that the
nation is for
the nation only and here's where this
gets super wild the fact that the rest
of the world
cares so much about the amazon
rainforest isn't perceived as a reason
to protect it
it's perceived by these people as a
threat it's like a claim on their
sovereignty it's
it's thought of as internationalization
after all like legitimately
what right do i as an american have to
tell brazil what to do with its
rainforests
in america we have deforested everything
we can so our interest in protecting it
actually becomes a reason for some
people
to want to destroy it if you live in a
world where everything is a zero-sum
game why should anyone else benefit from
our property and then there's the
reality that the amazon is not
as we sometimes imagine it empty there
are many indigenous people
other people who live and work in the
forest and who rely on the forest for
their livelihoods but
those people are often not seen as
real brazilians by these nationalists
nationalism is exclusionary ideology and
that's why fascism
nationalism and racism so often
walk together but here's the thing um of
course if the if the
amazon rainforest was 100 pasture land
in soybeans
that would not just be a disaster for
the whole world it would be
even more of a disaster for brazil
itself see how hot
it is in northern africa that's actually
farther away from the equator
than brazil is brazil receives more
solar energy than saudi arabia but
because of the rainforest it is much
more cool
this is the effect of that
evapotranspiration the rainforest
makes rain if there is less of it it is
clear that it would be
hotter and drier and these man-made
fires or even the natural ones
will spread on their own leading to a
feedback loop
that could end the amazon and 70 of the
gdp of south america
is made in places where amazon
rainforest
rain falls even here in america again
internationalization for you
much of the rain that falls here is
evapo transpired
in the amazon rainforest and an
important note when i talk about
rainfalling
really what i'm talking about is
agriculture i'm talking about
food we eat that rain there's a lot of
talk about tipping points and i think
it's important to note that there are
always many tipping points
along the path to something being
completely destroyed but yes
there is a time when less and less water
falls in the rainforest and fires happen
more and more often
and there is a time where we lose most
if not
all of the amazon and it's why we have
science to warn us about stuff like this
so that we can take action and it's why
we have human rights
to protect people whose land is their
land
whose life is their life but it is all
too easy to deny stuff like this when
you have more of an allegiance to your
ideology
than you do to the truth and that is
something that i like to try and say to
myself
constantly it's why we need to call a
lie a lie no matter who says it it's why
we need to say
that the rainforest is not burning it is
being burned
john i'll see you on tuesday obviously
this is a big and complicated thing and
this is a short video
so i've linked to a bunch of other
resources the article in the intercept
from a few months ago that basically
predicted all of this
was my favorite resource for this but
there are lots of other smart people
talking about it and it seems like
people are having a better idea of what
exactly is going on
and why it's happening so and i guess
thanks for caring about this because
because that's a big deal and it is the
only way we have slowed
this in the past